[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
meine letzte brunch und frühstücks idee
hatte ich ja super gut gefallen da wir
mit der er es zusammen kleine brötchen
gebacken im tontopf mit zur kleinen
frischkäse küken und bärlauch butter
heute gibt es eine weitere frühstücks
idee und zwar machen wir frühstücks
muffins aus der muffin form und die
werden richtig lecker mit spinat und
etwas schafskäse bekommt später noch mit
reinen als in der mitte im prinzip
könnte es auch abwandeln ich mache jetzt
mit einem quark öl teig wird aber statt
quark etwas joghurt benutzen für den
joghurt öl teig verwende ich 300 gramm
mehl einen teelöffel backpulver 1 1
teelöffel salz etwas pfeffer und chili
40 milliliter sonnenblumenöl und 150
gramm käse sahne joghurt nämlich zuerst
die trockenen zutaten die kommen in eine
rührschüssel und ihr braucht für das
rezept auch keine küchenmaschine im
prinzip könnt ihr den teig auch gern mit
der hand verkneten
kurz die zutaten verrühren das ist auch
echt so ein typischer tag muss ich sagen
aus der türkischen küche dann nimmt man
halt joghurt da gibt es auch keinen
quark das ei dazu etwas öl
ich nehme dir sonnenblumenöl aber wer es
gerne mag kann auch unternehmen und den
sahnejoghurt
der gast die sahne joghurt er ist ganz
besonderes finde ich das nehme ich so
eine leichte säure also der ist nicht so
süßlich wie sonst immer joghurt finde
ich einfach so leicht säuerlich und
passt echt super des perfekt
seid ganz kurz berühren
so sieht datei jetzt aus und jetzt teile
ich ihnen zwölf portionen 1 könnte gerne
auch ein bisschen mehr nehme auf die
arbeitsfläche
[Applaus]
mit einem teig portion nehmen bisschen
ausrollen zu einem kreis dann könnt ihr
damit die massen form auslegen da habe
ich jetzt bereits papier förmchen drin
und so entsteht ein kleines körbchen
da kommt dann gleich die füllung 3
sind alle ausgekleidet jetzt die füllung
dran
die könnt ihr auch gerne vorher schon
vorbereiten für die füllung verwende ich
eine zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe einen
esslöffel olivenöl 100 gramm baby spinat
etwas salz und pfeffer und muskatnuss
einen halben bund petersilie 200 gramm g
schafskäse und zwölf keine eier
die zwiebel und die knoblauchzehe wenn
jetzt fein gewürfelt und das öl kann ich
schon mal in einer pfanne erhitzen
[Musik]
dann die zwiebel und knoblauch wir viel
anbraten bis sie schön glasig sims und
wenn ihr kein baby spinat habe sondern
großen dann könnte den jetzt auch noch
ein bisschen schneiden und ich kann
ihnen da zwischenzeit schon mal den
schafskäse zerbröseln
[Musik]
zu den zwiebeln gebe ich jetzt den
spinat so mein lieblingsspruch zieht
jetzt macht ganz viel aus aber gleich
selber zusammen und dann ist es wohl
ganz wenig das ist bereits jetzt noch
salz und pfeffer rein und ein bisschen
muskat
fertig das weiß ich schon der ganze
zauber alles ist vorbereitet dass mit
dem spinat ist optional wenn er sagt es
muss wirklich super schnell gehen dann
lasst das mit dem spinat wegnimmt
einfach hier die zutaten gerne noch
speck oder so druck zum beispiel dazu
dann ist nämlich noch schneller jetzt
habe ich hier meine förmchen da setzt
sich unten rein erstmal ein bisschen
käse und da ich mich jetzt für
schafskäse entschieden weil er einfach
schön witzig ist wenn ihr absolut kein
schafskäse fans seid könnt ihr euch
jetzt ein käse nehmen der ist auch schön
würzig was ich persönlich nicht so
markus ziegenkäse aber da ist murat der
totale fan also da wählt ihr einfach den
käse den ihr gerne habt aber scharf
diese passt schon super dazu dann einen
hauch petersilie etwas spinnert vorsicht
heiß nicht verbrennen
und jetzt kommt der wichtige partie habe
jetzt hier kleine eier
wenn ihr aber keine eier größe es findet
könnt ihr auf euer in der größe im
nehmen und dann macht ihr es so dass wir
jetzt zum frühstücksei immer film und
damit das ganze nicht überläuft weil
einfach das allzu groß ist trenne ich
jetzt das ei zuerst setzt dann erst das
eigelb rein und dann ist ein weiß
darüber so kann ich sicher gehen dass
nichts überschwappt
das reicht schon weiß was dann übrig ist
kann ich einfach weiter verwenden und
kann zum beispiel machen also bitte
nicht wegschütten oder einfach noch
überall
wenn ihr diese weise sind gehört könnte
es sogar besser funktionieren weil es
dann nicht mehr so zusammenhängt als
wird sehr kommt jetzt noch schafskäse
auf das 1
so kann ich auf zusätzliches salz
verzichten treffer mache ich aber erst
nach dem backen und die kommen jetzt bei
mir in den vorgeheizten backofen und je
nachdem ob die eier hartgekocht oder
noch ein bisschen weich haben möchtet
müsst es eben länger oder ein bisschen
kürzer treten lassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die muffins sind jetzt gebacken und ich
habe es jetzt ein bisschen abkühlen
lassen ich finde sie schmecken auch warm
und kalt sehr gut also könnte auch super
vorbereitet
und wenn ihr möchtet können die sie gern
noch mal mit petersilie bestreuen und
auch nochmal mit dem schafskäse ganz wie
ihr wollt
sie mag so probieren da sind heftige
motto es ist dann auch die große stimmt
ja und ich habe ja auch schon mal ich
glaube aprikosen muffins gemacht aber so
ist diese aussagen aber die haben sie es
da wussten wir nicht ob sie jetzt ob sie
groß und alles ist aus dem ofen genommen
habe ich habe warte 18 minuten gestellt
plus noch mal drei also 21 minuten
da war das noch ein bisschen weich wenn
man sie dann direkt aus der muffin form
rausnimmt bleibt auch weil ich wenn man
es drin deshalb nochmal und spinat
schafskäse ein bisschen möglich ja aber
ich glaube ich würde bei mir selber noch
ein bisschen schafskäse darauf mache ich
habe auch schon 1 abgeben ist nur ein
probiert und ich würde sie nie vergessen
einen tag habe ich sogar chili aber wir
zwei so schiller es ist und ich glaube
alle anderen finden schaaf nur wenig
guckt mal in der mitte richtig genial
ich finde auch die schichten schön käse
mit spinat und petersilie oben das schon
fühlen und dann nehmen wir das noch für
die jungs mit
und das rezept findet ihr auch sally
blog.de
vielleicht wollte erst mal nachmachen
wie gesagt für ein frühstück aber auch
zum abendessen finde ich sie genial oder
zum picknicken also ihr könnt die auch
super überall hin mitnehmen wenn ihr das
rezept nach machen wollt dann findet ihr
es auch sallys - blog.de vielen dank
fürs einschalten und bis zum nächsten
mal
jetzt auch kohl auch zum mitnehmen fürs
büro für die arbeit
für die kinder für die schultasche
herzhafter fans cool herz auf der
muffins für kinder in die schule
also wenn ich damals rezepte haben wollt
dann denke ich mir was cooles aus
schreibt einfach in die kommentare
[Musik]